new york city planning to outlaw sales
of big sodas and other sweet drinks over
a certain size in an effort to curb
obesity the mayor is saying this is
about helping people lose weight if
approved the band could prevent
restaurants delis even movie theaters
from selling sugar drinks larger than 16
ounces I mean I think Bloomberg's a
douche I mean I think it kind of
infringes on our freedom you know what I
mean so I think that they should
encourage people to be more sensible
with their drinking habits um but I
don't think that the band should be put
in place I don't really support you know
government trying to meddle in your ear
thing I always said you know parents
should really monitor what their kids
eat it's kind of ridiculous to me to try
and tell people what they can have at
what sighs whatever to their choice I
understand that he wants people to eat
healthier but ultimately I don't think
it'll work if somebody doesn't
understand that drinking one 16-ounce
bottle as opposed to 20 ounce bottle as
bad for you what stops him from grabbing
two 16-ounce bottles are three or four
so I don't think it's going to have a
huge impact on the overall scheme of
things but I definitely commend him for
trying there's back there's actually
been a lot of bipartisan support for
Bloomberg's initiatives to ban you know
smoking in bars and in parks do you
think that at this from this one you
might have gone too far I think this is
just a little too far yeah yeah you're
smoking I get secondhand smoke so I
don't know if if him limiting some of
these personal rights to drink sugary
drinks is acceptable I think that might
be crossing the line some but I agree
with him on the smoking ban for sure a
lot of people have been in support of
the nanny state his smoking bans were
pretty popular and then he went to salt
and trans fat now it's kind of a vacay
now they came from me moment with sugary
drinks do you think people are going to
start resisting at any point um no I
think that Americans are in a deep
slumber and you know I think that this
might be something that might promote
some people to start thinking
actively about their democracy but I
think for right now most people are in a
slumber